this next question is kind of it's a
good question I think we're gonna get a
lot out of it but it's a lot as a little
bit of a longer question and I'm gonna
actually end up a reading and I think
twice first I'm just gonna read it
through here we go I've been working on
asking you this question for over a year
and this is the best way I can I think I
can articulate it everything I say falls
on deaf ears I try to give advice when
astir if someone is in trouble and they
don't listen to the sound advice
then later I try to get them listened to
someone else that might have more
credibility an author or podcaster
philosopher etc and they still won't
listen they tried their hardest to make
what solutions I'm trying to give don't
not apply to them because of X Y & Z all
excuses almost as if they are too good
to implement the advice because it came
from me and me alone literally solving
people's problems and they are
deliberately not listening it's not how
I present the information they should
use my tonality is just fine it's almost
as if they won't listen because they
know I'm right and I want to prove and
they want to prove I'm wrong by not
giving me the respect I feel the
majority of people see me as lesser not
worthy of respect or listening to even
though I use such obvious logic these
people continuously try to exercise
power over me
defiantly an extreme non influential
presence even with logic tact
respectfulness no one wants to listen to
me people just refuse to even
respectfully move out of the way when
I'm trying to get around them not even
strangers people I live with I don't
understand what it is about me that most
people don't respect everyone seems to
have the attitude to defy or oppose
everything I say no matter the
circumstances whether I'm trying my best
to lead give advice etc people won't
listen to me they won't get behind me I
lack so much influence it's not funny I
try but to no avail
what do you
think so look it's it's a it's it's it's
a rough situation right lay it like I
feel for the individual in that
situation I feel you know I think I
imagine the frustration that you feel
being in that position where you're just
no one's listening to you that being
said you know we have a situation here
where you can see a lot of it is based
on everyone else's problems and not mine
so it starts off everything I say falls
on deaf ears so even even that statement
right there even that statement right
there out of the gate it's not well it's
not what I'm saying it's that they are
deaf correct yeah so that right there's
this we're opening opening salvo is
you're not listening to me then I try to
give advice when asked or if someone is
in trouble and they don't listen to
sound advice again whose fault is that
I'm giving you sound advice and everyone
else they're not listening continues on
then I try to get them to listen to
someone else that might have more
credibility an author or podcaster
philosopher and they still won't listen
and I'm sitting there thinking myself I
wonder what that sounds like
right I imagine that it sounds something
like you know usually Hackworth says the
exact same thing is me or uh or uh you
know you might want to listen to some
sam harris because if you listen some
sam harris you listen some tim ferriss
you'll see the light on this meaning i'm
over here i already see the light you
know you might want to you might want to
check out the light with me or you know
Marcus Aurelius is a monastic Stoics you
might want to check him out so I feel
like there's a little you know you're
just bolstering your opinion by offering
other people that that that you agree
with and now it's supposed to give it
clout it's kind of the feeling I get a
little bit okay we continue on then they
try their hardest to make
what solutions I'm trying to give
doesn't apply to them because of XYZ all
excuses and again now instead of saying
hey well what way am i explaining these
that people have got perfect solutions
allegedly which again that's a huge
that's a huge assumption is that my
solutions are freaking perfect and they
just won't listen but instead of saying
that it's like oh maybe my solutions
number one aren't that great or number
two maybe I'm not explaining them out
very well but none of this is my fault
is their fault nerds making excuses that
it's not on me and then it continues
almost as if they are too good to
implement the advice because it came
from me and me alone and and this is
where you start to hear that it's worse
sir I start to get a little bit of a
sense of the mindset of the individual
because the individuals perception that
they don't and that people don't like or
people don't respect them the individual
it causes them it causes that individual
to act in ways that they that that
individual doesn't even perceive
themselves mmm-hmm so what shows through
again intent has a smell what shows
through is frustration what shows
through is resentment you know what I'm
saying
resentment shows through you can't hide
resentment annoyance when you're annoyed
that people are listen to each shows
through arrogance show when you're when
you think you have the perfect solution
and that's how you're coming across
that's how you're talking people that
shows through mmm-hmm
and so although that that perception
that people don't like me that
perception that I'm that that people are
looking down on me that perception that
you have of yourself shows through it it
comes across in a bad way the next
sentence literally solving people's
problems and they are deliberately not
listening again none of this has to do
with me none of it has to do with mices
my solutions themselves none of it has
to do with any that they just don't like
me it's their fault
and by the way in doing that we have to
assume that these people are just gonna
fail because they're not listening so I
would rather fail than listen to Fred
here mm-hmm and then he can't and then
this is just it's not how I present the
information they should use my tonality
is just fine yeah right yeah right this
is not my fault my tonality is my
tonality is fine like the way I'm
presenting look look I'm presenting this
in the most just beautiful way yeah it's
not it's not on me it's not my fault my
tonality is actually perfect the way I
present my ideas is so good you know
it's funny it's like I know you're
exaggerating but it's for a good reason
I yeah they try to make the point yeah
exactly right and that's good because
you know I'm I'm putting myself in his
shoes where I'm like my tonality is fine
like what do you what does it feel like
when you for real believe that your
tonality is fine you say but that's fine
like but really what it really is is and
never never really thought about it just
it doesn't stand out is not fine to me
you know so it's like yeah my tone is
fine I'm gonna include that in there
just so we all know kind of thing right
that feels for me yeah in reality it's
like oh is it fine just fine because
apparently not right so that's why you
exaggerate it to help it stand out as a
thing you something but yes thank you
that's what I like too analogies fine
that's what I felt you might as well
have said my tonality is the most
perfect tonality in the history of yeah
yeah cuz yeah because that's not
something that you would even think
about yeah yeah you just be like as a
person say yeah but you go through it
you think you know what the way I talk
to everyone is actually fine it's
actually good yeah if it wasn't I would
know about it he asked Lear to stand out
to me yeah exactly
next one next sentence it's almost as if
they won't listen to me because they
know I'm right and they want to prove
I'm wrong by not giving me the respect
all kinds of insecurity issues right
there all kinds of all kinds of
insecurity and that insecurity comes
across and it doesn't come across as
like
you know echos kind of insecure but
we'll listen you know it comes across as
you're over compensating by a long shot
and by the way it's almost as if they
won't listen to me because they know I'm
right I mean that's just crazy talk
right how many times echo Charles how
many times have you heard me say I know
I'm right and there's some things that
I'm pretty knowledgeable about yeah
right
yeah there's some things that I'm pretty
knowledgeable right about and how many
times have I and I don't know what this
I don't even know what this guy does for
a living
but let's say maybe well there's no
talent but even a master of something
shouldn't say I know I'm right yeah very
very very seldom yeah very seldom man
especially that right there I know I'm
right
there's a difference between like I know
this is true or I know this how about
this I think this is true okay I'm
talking like there's no one the next
level yeah okay so okay yeah if you want
to say any factual like like he was
there he was that person was there at
that location like I know that that's
true like that's different than saying I
know I'm right about this you know I
know I'm right I know yeah no you have
never said that meanwhile this guy is
saying it and and by the way you know
this is like you started starting to get
into the hey everyone is against me no
every like the whole world everyone that
I that I deal with they all don't listen
to me what is wrong with everyone else
right this isn't even like hey look you
and I had a little disagreement I'm
gonna take ownership of it and just say
it's my fault no this is everyone yeah
continuing on I feel the majority of
people see me as lesser not worthy of
respect or listening to even though
listening even though I use such obvious
logic
now this is this is where I start to
feel like a sympathy right like cuz now
you got this bad low self-esteem low
self opinion and when you see yourself
as lesser than you start to
overcompensate for it many people start
to overcompensate and you know they
start to try and act like yeah they
start to say things like I use obvious
logic yeah there's a whole genre of
people who like to use the terms facts
logic and and and and so when they say
well you don't want Jocko look I come at
people with facts and logic and
sometimes it just pisses them off in
what they don't you know what I mean
it's it's it's that it's the thing that
it's one of the things that that you say
you refer back to a lot which is when
someone says you know hey I'm just a
Thai person just have to deal it if they
feel the same way about saying look I
just deal in facts and logic and you
know people just need to people can't
accept you and what are you gonna say
well you know lies are better or it's
one of those it's kind of like you put
yourself on a you know in a position of
authority right listen I like to use
facts and logic as like irrefutable yeah
I I use facts and logic and other people
are just emotional and crazy and
obviously everyone so just listen to me
so that's kinda that's kind of a a
little bit of that tonality here so it
continues these people and by the way
the people is in quotes okay the people
is in quotes these people as if they're
subhumans yes these people continuously
try to exercise their power over me
defiantly an extreme and then this is
kind of weirdly worded sentence an
extreme non influential presence even
with logic tact and respectfulness so
he's talking about himself no one wants
to listen to me
so saying that you have tact
respectfulness and logic I mean this is
this is there's no ownership about the
message about the delivery about the
tonality about the attitude everything
is everyone else's fault and by the way
like this is one of those things where
if he was talking about you know I got
this one department and the two senior
people in the department they have a
real then you start thinking okay well
you know maybe they maybe they got some
ego and maybe you need a massage there
either we'll work through that this is
everyone this is we're talking about you
know everyone that I'm interacting with
doesn't listen to me
they they disrespect me it continues on
people just refuse to even respectfully
move out of the way when I'm trying to
get around them not even strangers
people I live with this this statement
first of all why not move around other
people right that's first of all second
of all you ever hear when someone says
oh I was thinking about buying a
Corvette and now everywhere I look I see
Corvettes yeah and this is the same
thing where he feels disrespected now
anytime anybody's in his way
it's there are straight-up disrespecting
him for yeah
continues on I don't understand what it
is about me that most people don't
respect everyone seems to have the
attitude to defy or oppose everything I
say no matter the circumstance whether
I'm trying my best to lead give advice
etc people won't listen to me they won't
get behind me I lack so much influence
it's not funny I try but to no avail
what do you think so here's what I think
to this individual
stop trying so hard
stop trying so hard to lead stop trying
so hard to influence stop trying so hard
to give advice to everybody leadership
starts with following people that's how
that's not that's that's where
leadership starts
I would say assessing what I'm reading
that you lack real true confidence real
true confidence you have some false
bravado that makes you say it's obvious
and I'm logical that's not real I think
you lack and and the the lack of
confidence comes through all over this
thing
and so does the overcompensation
so oddly enough let me tell you
something start training jiu-jitsu it's
a strange thing to say right a strange
thing to say start lifting weights those
are those are two things I'm gonna say
start training jiu-jitsu start lifting
weights why because you lack confidence
and those things will start to give you
confidence start listening to people
instead of always feeling like you need
to give your two cents start listening
to people it actually takes confidence
to listen right all right about that in
leadership strategy and tactics it takes
extreme like confidence to accept other
people's ideas that takes the highest
level of confidence and if you don't
know that then you're constantly trying
to show that you don't need to listen
their ideas so start listening to other
people start trying to support their
plans instead of trying to force your
great ideas down everyone's throat
because right now you don't have
relationship with anybody all you do is
you you're costly outbound that people
do this do that it's always about you so
start following other people start
supporting other people it takes
confidence takes true confidence to
follow it takes true confidence to
support other people and right now you
don't have that kind of confidence you
don't have that kind of humility and so
you act arrogant and that's that right
there is probably why no one listens to
you because you act arrogant so force
yourself to be humble force yourself to
listen force yourself to follow and over
time you will start to be appreciated
and when people start to appreciate that
you and the way you behave then people
will start to listen to you and then
eventually you can you will be followed
by people
and all that right there starts off with
you taking ownership of your shortfalls
instead of blaming everyone else because
that's exactly what this whole thing is
and if you want to go through life
blaming everyone else for everything
that doesn't go your way then you
actually have no power over it and
you'll just continue in this situation
forever but if you want actually take
ownership of it you can fix the
shortfalls which are yours they're your
shortfalls and then you can become
eventually the leader that you want to
be otherwise you continue down this path
of blaming everyone else not changing
yourself then you will continue to be
not listened to not respected this is
like this is an extreme case really it's
an extreme case it's an extreme case and
I I really hope I mean I truly hope that
this individual is really listening yeah
because the way that this individual
feels about everyone else it's gonna be
really smooth chocolate idiot yeah
another or another one of those people
people yeah won't listen to my logic
yeah and and it makes that actually
honestly it makes me sad it makes me sad
to see someone in the state yeah it does
well then and I don't want to come off
like an extreme case like I'm this like
expert but I will say that well I think
we all are the same but you say speaking
of arrogance peak we're all in the same
boat to say we know what this is like we
know people like this all the time yeah
yes like you know I'm not like
disparaging Fitness people at all but
you ever had an extreme fitness person
where if you ate some bubble gum they'd
be like you know much sugars in that
bubble gum the thing is Brad that's all
true all that facts all those facts and
logic and all this stuff oh yeah okay
they're not gonna land though because
breath okay so I used to I used to get
into arguments but little things with my
brother where he
heed everyone said well he's not an
extreme case but every once in a while
he'll bust out some debate stuff you
know out of nowhere right where you know
how someone will say something and
they're they're just talking casually
and then you'll be like hey what you
said there's no right and remove your
all this stuff right yeah no one likes
that no one likes that you no matter how
correct no matter so what what I wound
up telling them to try to sum up the
whole thing I said what you're saying is
right but what you're doing is wrong and
so it's like there's another level to it
and you know like all this facts and
logic whatever we have told that to your
brother yes like when you when you wait
you guys were in a debate of some kind
no you were just give him a general sort
of overview of his existence Oh scolding
him before getting people into debates
all the time you know like it mean
you're talking like there was this time
I think this is what prompted it where
me and Terry were and we were just
talking about kids you know just kind of
raising kids and we're like doing this
and this and he was sort of listening
and kind in the conversation but I was
talking to and he's and we're talking
about something I forget exactly what it
was but something about like how if you
do this this will create this response
with the kids and then we're like but
what if it had the reverse response or
whatever and he chimed in with something
like oh no it would have this initial
response and I'm like well but you could
stand to reason that look they might
respond like this you know kind of just
just talking though like isn't it
interesting anything and then meanwhile
I'm talking to Terry by the way mmm and
facilitating Jade's comments but I'm
more talking to Terry anything he then
he interrupts Anka's no no there's
studies about this and then and then I'm
like everyone's kind of like pause and
was like oh he's really aggressive right
now he even said afterwards it's like
I'm sorry that came off whatever he
likes to do that oh yeah big time and
that's why why I ain't Wanda when I say
scolding it's like brother that's your
brother so it's not even scolding but
nonetheless it's yeah like what you're
saying regardless of what it is like if
you're if you have all these ear a logic
irrefutable logic and facts and all this
stuff like brother that's all correct
but what you're doing is wrong what what
just one thing that really bothers me
about this is I actually know
100% which I just talked about not
saying I know that an individual in this
situation can turn it around yes so I
know they can turn it around yes there's
a in leadership strategy and tactics I
have a section called conform to
influence it just talks about like hey
basically what you just said you know
when the fitness person's like hey you
should work out every day at four
o'clock in the morning and people are
like hey dude I'm not gonna listen to
you cuz you're barking at me you're
offensive to me yeah you know I had that
I had this question at the muster in
Australia from the female that was like
hey I love health I care about health
I'm working out every morning I'm trying
to get everyone motivated I'm telling
them that they shouldn't be eating what
they're eating for lunch I'm telling
them they should come work out with me
afterwards and she's basically not part
of the crew yeah they're all just
looking at her thinking just be quiet
and I said why don't you form some
relationships with the people so that
they start to listen to you so that's
another kind of overlying to or our
underlying tone here is you don't have
relationships with anybody why are they
gonna listen to anything that you say
yeah form relationships with people how
do you do that you listen to them you
follow them you support them yeah that
is like you say that you can recover
from it and that yeah but it's not gonna
be the next day man it's in fact oh yeah
yeah for sure he's got he's got a little
campaign he's got a big campaign because
the same way that you look at the
Corvette thing that you do and you're
always seeing the Corvettes everywhere
and so it's like this kind of pattern of
thought right where now he looks at
everyone as like oh I just can't wait
like it's almost like he's waiting for
them anticipating them towards
disrespect them or whatever and that's
just how but the same it's a two-way
street
people are not waiting for him to say
some BS to them now he's gonna roll in
the room people like here comes whatever
let this crap let me throw a hypothesis
at you
the reason I think it might be a little
not as hard as you think it would be is
because I bet people don't really have
these horrible feelings about them I bet
they're just you know it's kind of like
oh yeah like when
say oh you know I don't when they say to
them I don't think we're gonna do it
that way he's thinking see they don't
listen and they're really just thinking
well it seems like there's a problem
with that you know there seems like
that'd be a little logistical II
complicated you know and he doesn't hear
that he just hears they hate me and they
don't listen to me that's possible so it
might not be you know it's I got I get
asked sometimes you know well um you
know I'm a female and and the guys are
thinking this or I'm a man I'm working
these women and they're thinking that
and I go you know who probably is
thinking the most about being a man in
that room yeah you you just probably
thinking the most about being a woman
you know I've been taught I've had
female leaders come and brief me over
and over again and I'm not thinking oh
it's a woman I'm gonna see it from this
perspective are there some people that
do that sure but most people are like oh
what's what what is she talking about
so there's a good chance that all that
some of this is just in his head it's
some of it is just in his head and the
person that's thinking about this the
most is actually him yeah it's possible
it's also possible that well I miss this
much I can promise you these people are
not going home and thinking about him
all night yeah I can promise you that's
not happening maybe two of them are yeah
he's going home and thinking about them
all day all night he's thinking about
how much they disrespect him how much
they're not thinking about that they
don't move out of his way he somebody
you know he walks down the hallway and
wants to get into the the freaking
refrigerator room and someone's in the
way and and you know they kind of like
let go first yeah they never think about
that moment he's dwelling on it don't
dwell on it man no one's thinking about
it just be this be cool list and other
people be humble that's rough too like
if you if that's in your mind like
people just won't even get out of my way
when I'm trying to go randoms like
walbro that's like some sensitive
like brother that's where you're finding
this soup right you're finding Corvettes
everywhere you wanted Corvettes
everywhere you look is a Corvette even
Corvettes that are Corvettes start
looking like Corvettes you know you
start seeing you know Fiero
yeah Fieros I'm looking like yes
unfortunately you start looking like
that Corbin yeah but and yeah yeah to me
as far as me goes that's true but at the
same time everyone could know this about
this guy everyone could have this like
notion of this guy that this is who this
guy is or any he's so annoying every
little thing that I do he's he has some
advice to make it different or better
you know even those guys you don't think
about them when they're not there well
yeah right yeah even those guys yeah
when they show up you're like oh here
comes Billy yeah with this and somebody
named bill by the way hit me up on
social media
why is all the bad guys named Bill okay
so let's say Dan Darren you know yeah
you got little Darren coming nd god
here's Darren with his loud mouth he's
got his own ideas yeah when the Aaron
leaves I'm not thinking about Darren
it's not driving me crazy I'm not
writing I'm not taking a year he took a
year to formulate this email a year to
formula so he's thinking about this all
the time for a year yeah to try and
articulate it the right way which by the
way according to him he did he did
articulate it the right way he says I've
been working on ask you this question
for over a year and this is the best way
I think I can articulate it this is it
the best way yeah okay so there's this I
thought you're gonna comment at least on
the fact that I told him to start
training jiu-jitsu yeah what right I
have nothing that yes sir in jiu-jitsu
isn't it it's a real thing real help
yourself confidence yeah hang around
with some other people get choked out
get an arm locked you're lifting weights
yeah maybe you're getting in shape maybe
one of those results one of the many
results of that might be but you won't
be compelled to try to correct everybody
everywhere you go like okay so sometime
like I want to say all the time but if
people aren't asking for like advice not
all the time sometimes it works but if
they're not asking for advice he can't
just just well unsolicited be correcting
people how often are you walking around
just standing by and hoping that
everyone gives you advice on stuff
there's not a lot of people like that
yeah I mean it's really rare but there
is a time okay back to my brother Jade
you stuck in sand with his trunk why so
he wasn't stuck stuck but he was he was
getting stuck right and we could all see
him he was kind in the distance there
and he started starting to get stuck and
there's all kinds of techniques to get
unstuck in saying all kinds of technics
range but there's a protocol it's pretty
standard or whatever so he's beginning
to get stuck in our other friend Richard
who is he the most tactful guy in the
world
sounds like a man every single moment of
his life maybe maybe not and then at
this particular moment it wasn't so I
see Richard walking over there about to
go give Jade some advice on how to not
get stuck right is he qualified to give
advice and his age should Jade be taking
advice at this point okay
well that's another question to me if
you're about to get stuck if it really
seems like you're about to get stuck and
someone's gonna offer you advice to not
get stuck yeah I think logically right
you should take the advice but little
we're dealing with the real world here
so Jade's about to get stuck Jade has a
protocol in his mind right he's not like
unaware of this protocol but he has it
in his mind but according to what what
seemed like what it looked like was in
Richards mind he didn't so Richard
aggressively running over there
aggressively going over there to give
him some unsolicited advice which he
obviously needs right and we can't hear
any of the advice we can hear we only
see the body movements right and so you
see you know aggressively Richards
telling them whatever he's telling them
with his hand movements and all this
stuff you know Jade's like no reaction
you look kind when you're real annoyed
but you have no reaction you're just
like kind of looking down or whatever
and he's like doing his own protocol I
mean our Richards like coaching them
aggressively not landing at all falling
on deaf ears as it were and every time
it's like
maybe five ten seconds Richard would
like turn around and throw his hands up
as if to say this guy's not listening to
me and he did that maybe three four
times right so you could tell it was not
going to it over there so I'm like all
right so we're all watching it me my
other brother and we're kind of laughing
a little bit because we see the scenario
we see Jade getting stuck ER and Stucker
and Richard and all we just see the
whole thing playing out so later on we
kind of talked to Jay kind of teasing
them right like brining you just just
like listen or whatever and he went into
the that side of the whole deal where
it's like men you can't like it's hard
to listen to on someone just like jumps
in your hole stressful situation
offering you all this like whack advice
in this whack kind of way yeah there
there there's a ways to deliver advice
in critical situations like that and
even then most likely an indirect
approaches advised and that's if the
okay and in this situation to hit or it
doesn't matter what it looked like to us
it looked what it looked like to richard
is like oh this guy obviously needs my
advice right now obviously any Jade's
mine he's like I know I've done this
before so so so I had a conversation
with somebody on EF online the other day
I was saying look in this situation you
you should approach with an indirect
approach and then as I'm talking to her
I can see that she's not she's kind of
annoyed and she actually was a like like
a logic and facts based thing look like
why can't I just say the logic can fax
with what's going on and then have
everyone just get on board with the
program it kind of was the thought
process right and I I said you know I
can see that this bothers you because
what you're saying from your perspective
is look I know the facts it doesn't make
any sense that I waste all this time
trying to you know take this indirect
approach to try and get someone to
understand the facts so we can change
the direction that we're going or adjust
the plan accordingly that's just dumb I
said I can see that on your face here's
the thing if you take a direct which
which is why we're having this
conversation by the way you
a direct approach and it doesn't work so
you don't adjust the plan I'm suggesting
you take an indirect approach which will
actually work and yes it will take a
little more time upfront but the result
will be positive so if Richard would
have taken an indirect approach and
walked over and and it would why should
I have to tell Jade that and uh why
should I have to take I could just tell
him hey you need to put it reverse
rocket or whatever advice he had to give
him if you'd have gone over and said you
know hey do you do you want me to tell
you where your tires are at or something
like that just a nice just a little
indirection she don't jump on his team
yeah just jump on his team and then all
of a sudden Jade's mind is openoffice in
there literally on the same team just by
saying hey you only put some weight on
the front for you or you know whatever
hey um you know do you want me to throw
some extra whatever you whatever you do
to get on the team and then you're
you're gonna win in the end and the
indirect approach which seems like a big
pain in the ass out of the gate oh my
god I can't believe I have to do this
and play this game I have to play this
game like yeah listen to what I'm
talking to you about play the game
because you will actually get
accomplished what you want to have get
accomplished as opposed to where you
know I'm just gonna open to take a
direct approach to tell them what's up
people aren't ready to receive it and so
it's useless and so true like you and
I'm thinking back to the tire to getting
stuck in the sand scenario to where and
here's the thing to do it to make it
matters worse like it's cabrito
it's reasonable to assume that how
Richard came up to him wasn't like hey
like we we got a problem let's do this
it wasn't that it was like a dummy stuck
in the sand dummy like you know what
you're doing kind of kind of it I'm not
sure what he said but it seemed like
that was the approach right not only the
direct approach it was just now you get
immediate defensive this I'm not listen
to anything you say
I won't ever get stuck out yet then
listen to you that was literally like
what I felt like it seems like Jade
right now would way rather get stuck and
then listen to rich
and quite frankly I don't blame him the
way Richard was like throwing up his
hands like oh my gosh you're so dumb
kind of the kind of a thing like again I
didn't hear what he said but that's what
that's what his body language was saying
I'll tell you that so man I kind of I
felt them I felt them so yeah man let's
hope that this guy here can actually
listen to what we're saying I mean it in
the most positive possible way I think
you can get out of this situation but
you got to take ownership of what's
going on and you got to make some real
changes hit us back up hit me back up on
that that'd be cool I'd like to hear how
it all works out there's one layer of
positive feedback
Jordan Peterson I think it was on Joe
Rogan alone you know how they make this
like Jordan versus yeah yeah okay so it
what he said God was part of um he got
made into that right part of it ended so
he was like um it was like everybody's
rejecting you everybody's rejecting yeah
it's you yeah right kind of thing and
it's funny because it's like did the
tone that he said it but that's kind of
irrefutable logic right there you know
where it's like man you're kind of like
the girl it's a joke I think I'm pretty
sure it's a joke the girl who goes
through the doctor and says hey like my
my finger hurts or whatever you know
like when I touch here like my finger
hurts or whatever and then the doctor
goes okay but the solution is don't
touch there you know kind of thing Fred
that's like it's real obvious to people
you know it's the tortured genius that
life talks about an extreme ownership oh
hey look I'm right and everyone else
just doesn't see the brilliance of my
you know what I'm doing look no one sees
how brilliant I am yeah no one sees how
brilliant I am the other two thumbs and
yeah it's just horrible for me and it's
like no actually maybe you're not right
[Music]
least something's not very nice your
approaches wrong